o bom dia bom dia pessoal obrigado
obrigado meu nome henrique e pra mim é
uma é uma grande honra estar aqui é uma
grande felicidade
e vou contar pra vocês se um dia vocês
quando passarem por aqui a gente fica
bem nervoso
a gente fica bem nervoso central aqui e
agora eu entrei o pior ainda não sei o
que fazer eu não posso sair correndo
mais
ela tem que continuar é o relógio está
contando
vou ficar em silêncio de um pouquinho né
não melhorou
então vamos vamos vamos começar vamos
falar um pouquinho só de porto alegre na
verdade sou natural daqui meu sotaque
meio misturado com um são paulo leste
com outras coisas mas pra mim é muito
legal estar de volta em porto alegre faz
uns dez anos que eu sair daqui a dez
anos que eu me formei em ciência da
computação e na verdade foi mais ou
menos quando descobri que não era isso
que eu queria fazer da vida né
eu acho que vou falar um pouquinho sobre
isso né sobre esse despertar essa essa
questão de que está fazendo aqui mesmo é
pra que a gente tá fazendo isso e porque
eu tomo as decisões que eu tomo eu acho
que é tão importante a gente falar em
educação e aprendizagem
eu acho que é muito legal tá aqui com
vocês hoje ao mesmo tempo é uma grande
responsabilidade porque né eu vejo
pessoas aqui que provavelmente tem muito
mais vivência que eu com educação muito
mais experiência então me sinto super
humilde e está falando com vocês é o
mesmo tempo estava ali tem algumas
centenas de pessoas vão ver na internet
agora que é uma coisa nova recentemente
e é engraçado pensar nisso né como a
nossa presença a nossa fala vai além do
espaço físico que a gente tá né mas tem
pessoas em lugares anônimos fora do
brasil talvez nos vendo a minha família
e minha esposa também assistindo é uma
coisa meio difícil de pensar e pior que
isso na verdade a gente olhar pra o
fenômeno teddy sente olhar é o que já
foi falado aqui hoje
nesse vídeo depois virá o pequeno porte
colocar na internet e de repente minha
filha que nasceu ainda daqui um tempo
ela vai ver esse vídeo na internet não é
e ela vai vir não só esse vídeo mas
todos os vídeos que já passaram por toda
a história dos tedx e da humanidade
e assim ela vai poder consumir e
assistir e escolher todo o conhecimento
já foi gerado e que cada vez mais está
sendo gerado nesses formatos inovadores
que permite que a gente assista em casa
que esses em qualquer lugar na internet
no óculos do google sabe se lá o que vai
acontecer daqui a 15 20 anos
então é uma grande responsabilidade e ao
mesmo tempo embora acho que para alguns
de nós é uma coisa meio nos causa
ansiedade pensa nisso pra eles vai ser
muito fácil né ela vai quando crescer
ela vai conseguir filtrar exatamente o
que ela quer ela vai conseguir procurar
coisas de maneira muito rápida e
escolher aquilo que ela quer aprender
para onde ela quer ir e engraçado que na
verdade provavelmente ela vai aprender
na escola porque não é a gente que vai
ensinar isso pra ela né como escolher o
que assistir à internet o que é bom que
não é bom
é uma coisa que talvez aproveite ela vai
nos ensinar ela vai me ensinar vai
promete conceder ensinar os avós dela a
procurar coisas na internet que ela quer
assistir
então a gente fala em inovação na
educação é um monte de coisas que a
gente não consegue entender direito e
que estão acontecendo e que estão
transformando nossas vidas e às vezes é
é basicamente parar pra pensar que está
acontecendo mesmo né
eu vou trazer alguns pontos aqui pra
gente e essa pergunta que eu coloco né e
se fosse a prender o motivo da nossa
existência não vai falar um pouco do
propósito da aprendizagem
eu queria falar um pouco que eu enxergo
que aprender e evoluir das 20h às
espécies no mundo vai querer fazer um
parêntesis de começar eu vou arriscar
que estava a falar uma coisa diferente
nova que acho que é um pouco do
propósito ted mas também uma coisa que
nunca falei antes então vamos ver se a
gente se vocês entendem que eu tento
falar mas a minha teoria seguinte que o
planeta ela existe e ele evoluiu a
partir do aprendizado era verdade é eu
sou formado de carbono hidrogênio
oxigênio nitrogênio
estou aqui desde o início dos tempos é
como se cada molécula tivesse acumulado
o conhecimento de toda a humanidade para
chegar hoje está onde estamos e onde
estou aqui hoje nem o planeta evoluiu ao
longo do tempo e ia pra evoluir a partir
do aprendizado né as espécies
os conjuntos de espécies e ecossistemas
são nada mais que grandes universidades
escolas locais que estão aprendendo
juntos e dessa forma evoluindo mais do
que isso
aprender a sobreviver e aí a gente pode
pegar o caso qualquer espécie no planeta
que sobreviveu e outras que não
sobreviveram
o quanto elas foram capazes de aprender
e se a gente pensar na nossa espécie é o
ser humano
a gente nunca foi mais forte a gente
nunca foi mais rápido
nunca foi que o enxerga melhor que ouvir
melhor é que tem tato melhor não tem
nenhum superpoder enquanto outras
espécies têm mas a gente conseguiu
combinar tudo isso né como a capacidade
cognitiva é a capacidade de aprender
rápido de ser flexível de se adaptar o
que permitiu que chegasse aqui hoje né
depois de milhares de anos de evolução
da nossa espécie é como sociedade tac
junto então a gente pensa nisso é o ser
humano sobreviveu curso somente por
causa de sua capacidade de aprender ea
pergunta é só aprender é sobre ver que a
pergunta é onde estamos hoje
ao mesmo tempo como diria é um educador
colombianos bernardo toro ao mesmo tempo
a gente tem de um lado uma sociedade
capaz de se comunicar em tempo real com
basicamente qualquer pessoa no mundo
onde pessoas podem assistir a uma pessoa
no mundo com acesso à internet consegue
assistir agora ao vivo é uma coisa
inacreditável fantástica e ao mesmo
tempo nós estamos à beira de um colapso
né na nossa sociedade da nossa economia
tudo está em risco né
é o nosso clima está mudando né o meio
ambiente
então como é que a gente chegou a esse
ponto onde para muitos a sobrevivência
da espécie está em xeque
de fato e muitos de nós podemos até
ignorar isso ser cínicos a respeito nené
mas com certeza ela vai nos afetar 100
vieram para o sul africano hoje vai
certamente afetará nossos filhos em
milhões de pessoas já estão sendo
afetadas
a cada dia no dia de hoje
em outra pergunta que vem disso a
aprender para que vai voltando o nosso
mundo maravilhoso da tecnologia e todo
mundo conectado
a gente aqui têm acesso a recursos
básicos para viver uma boa graça nossa
família na sociedade a sociedade a gente
mora então pra quê aprender né
eu posso não precisa aprender e lembrar
se perguntar para os jovens na sala de
aula principalmente jovens em escola
pública
eles não sabem responder não sabe nem
porque eles estão lá e aqueles que
tinham responder alguma coisa vai dizer
é que o pai a mãe quer que o estúdio é
porque esse tal de vestibular ou aqueles
mais ambiciosos vão dizer é porque eu
quero um emprego pagar para ter dinheiro
para comprar uma casa bem grande para
ter três carros eo tce último celular de
última geração
isso é ambicioso e isso é um jovem de
grandes ambições alcançou médico
reconhecido pra ter muito dinheiro e
viajar bastante então na verdade é como
se aprender for supérfluo na sociedade
em 21 ea pergunta que eu faço é para
onde nós vamos
é com essa atitude eu acho que o grande
desafio que a gente tem na educação hoje
é um grande desafio a gente na sociedade
como um todo que é para onde está indo
com essa atitude
então eu queria trazer um aspecto que
pra mim é super importante é como a
gente muda isso léo como é que sei lá se
hoje eu tô aqui é muito é de que ele me
expor um pouco talvez querendo terminar
uma ideia mas o que isso eu diria que é
uma uma vontade de me testar é eu sempre
fui muito tímido assim mas se eu fosse
falar vamos pensar nisso quando era
adolescente eu seria incapaz de imaginar
falando aqui pra vocês e promete as
primeiras vezes que eu falei pra mais de
dez pessoas deve ter sido um fracasso na
escola quando tinha fazer uma
apresentação eu passava mal
e mais uma coisa que aconteceu comigo eu
acho que acontece com muitos jovens ea
cura
é essa hum se eu fizesse isso ou porque
não é aquela a que ele talvez um brilho
no olho talvez uma vontade de pensar né
a fazer isso e aí é uma questão de
atitude tem um estudo que eu li
recentemente que ele fala que até
criança de 4 anos ela já tem na cabeça
uma idéia de um modelo mental que leva
elas a serem curiosas ou não e está
relacionada por exemplo com a nossa
disposição a enfrentar desafios novos em
fazer coisas diferentes e fazer coisas
talvez mais difíceis do que a gente está
acostumado a fazer
então o teste que eles fizeram foi com
quebra cabeça né 0 para crianças
perceberam algumas crianças gostavam de
fazer sempre o mesmo tipo de quebra
cabeça que lhe dava satisfação pra elas
pelas conseguiu resolver aplicar a
cabeça e outras resolverem um queria um
maior seria o mais difícil
isso a gente consegue perceber muito de
mudar a sua vida adulta
quer dizer quantos de nós são capazes de
se sentir empolgados se sentir
entusiasmados quando recebe um novo
desafio de assumir novo trabalho uma
nova função ou algo de novo acontece em
nossa vida algo diferente e quantos de
nós se sentem acuados system atenciosos
com medo de fazer algo diferente
arriscar de tentar algo que pode dar
errado né
no final das contas então essa
curiosidade é o que diferencia essas
pessoas aquelas que há risco algum novo
poder errar mas também poderão muito
legal e aquelas que preferem ficar no
mesmo e aprender a crescer
eu acho que da minha parte eu eu
acredito que quando a gente aprende
quando se arrisca a gente sempre
desenvolvem sempre melhor é acertando ou
errando então né eu eu me lembro quando
eu estava nos tempos de colégio é e era
difícil é tentar uma coisa diferente
ainda mais tímida eu acho que sem
corante tentar algo novo mesmo que não
dê certo a gente está diferente está
crescendo
aí e despertar isso é é extremamente
importante e vou chegar lá mas também
tem uma questão de se adaptar
nem é uma questão ligada à nossa eu não
ser humano né que foi capaz de fazer
isso ao longo do tempo ea nossa
capacidade de quando as coisas mudam a
gente ter conseguido dar um passo para o
lado conseguir virar pra lá olhar de um
lado diferente né se virar certa maneira
e tudo começa a despertar e eu posso
contar um pouquinho meu respeito é eu
estudei ciência da computação mec em
porto alegre e morava com meus pais
desde pequeno e pra mim foi um processo
que aconteceu em pequenas pílulas de
momentos onde eu me senti diferente
momentos onde eu eu percebi que eu podia
agir
eu podia tomar escolhas e aquilo ali
tinha um impacto que talvez para os
outros não fosse relevante ou não fosse
perceptível mas pra mim fazer uma
diferença e acho que demorou 10 anos
para perceber o que estava acontecendo o
poder dizer o que era eu poder olhar
para trás ea daquele dia ali alguma
coisa aconteceu diferente né é uma
questão acho que para muitos e muitos
jovens é que acabou escolhendo carreira
mas por influência dos pais dos amigos
ou do que está acontecendo ao redor das
circunstâncias do que realmente o que
eles realmente querem fazer de fato eu
fico imaginando que seria minha vida se
tivesse despertado mais cedo nem quando
estava no ensino médio por exemplo
quando era criança isso vai acontecer um
pouco mais tarde cantou na faculdade
então se para alguns é pra mim no meu
caso foi quase não tenha informado nem
eu me formei na faculdade mas pra
entregar o diploma os pais de 37 anos
vai informar por que no fundamental no
processo de despertar no processo de
explorar
eu não preciso desaprender muitas coisas
né eu acho que contar uma historinha é
só pra mim foi muito marcante eu estava
na faculdade no segundo ano no primeiro
ano da faculdade 18 19 anos e foi com
amigos pro peru da bolívia na década de
90 foi o da união
eu me lembro disso porque o tempo estava
maluco por lá e ea gente viajou de
ônibus a viagem toda essa é aquela coisa
de mochileiro mesmo para explorar um
novo país e eu me lembro quando chega na
fronteira com a bolívia
estava com muito medo eu estou
extremamente preocupado que eles iam me
roubar me seqüestrar até com a imagem do
egito na bolívia assinam o país
extremamente perigoso e frágil e o que
você vai fazer lá né para muitos será a
sua passagem para chegar no peru e na
verdade o que aconteceu ao longo da
viagem eu passei cerca de cinco semanas
seis semanas viajando é que eu encontrei
um país extremamente sim verdade pobre
mas extremamente pessoas alegres pessoas
amigáveis pessoas é que me ajudaram
muito nada aconteceu
neo caminhava na rua noite pegava ônibus
sobretudo nada aconteceu naquele tempo
só coisas boas e aprendi a falar
espanhol na viagem que eu não sabia
falar eu me interessei queria aprender
espanhol mas o mais importante é que eu
percebi que tudo que tinham falado pra
mim até então né era de certa maneira
uma mentira né
o que a televisão tinha me contado com a
escola me contava o que os teus pais
certa maneira de falar sobre aquele país
aquelas pessoas era uma mentira porque
era minha realidade na minha percepção
da minha vivência era um país muito
legal eu queria muito voltar e eu fiquei
eu senti saudade até hoje então
desaprender aquilo que a gente aprende é
extremamente importante
muitas coisas são ditas que a gente não
vivenciou a gente ouviu falar que assim
ouviu falar que aquilo que muitas coisas
são simplesmente vivenciado de uma
maneira e depois a gente precisa
aprender que na verdade as coisas podem
ser diferentes
é uma coisa que eu aprendi que as
verdades são muito menos absolutos que a
gente imagina
e aí a gente precisa reaprender então
pra mim o processo de aprender foi em
grande parte continuar viajando e eu
descobrir quanto mais esse lugar é assim
imagina outros países é como é que eles
não devem ser diferentes do que imagina
minha cabeça né e alguns anos atrás de
oportunidade de passar um tempo na china
e foi exatamente
sim extremamente um país o país de uma
cidade no caso de xangai muito
desenvolvida rica extremamente fácil de
me locomover segura né e é pra quem já
tem qualidade pra lá o que estiver
curioso para conhecer vai porque é de
surpreender com diferente é do que a
gente imagina que era o que eu imaginava
que era e dois outros pontos que a falar
sobre isso é nesse processo desaprender
e reaprender eu estou falando aqui de
educador do papel de educador e nem vou
falar nisso vou deixar outras pessoas
falarem eu tô falando indivíduo que
passa por esse processo o que acontece
ao longo do tempo a gente desenvolver um
que eu chamo de autocontrole que aquela
capacidade que a gente entende né
segurar os impulsos de se falou aqui que
a internet não se distrai
mas se a gente tiver um pouquinho de
autocontrole disciplina saber as coisas
a gente consegue usufruir de tudo da
melhor maneira possível
autocontrole aqui pra mim não falar
demais não passar no meu tempo respeitar
o tempo de vocês e do intervalo que vem
a seguir é isso é algo que é muito
difícil aprender a gente aprende na
escola
infelizmente até hoje num não ouvi muito
falar disso
a gente aprende a partir de experiências
práticas na vida e eu acho que isso é
algo muito importante a gente continuar
e aí vem o acho que o final das contas e
desenvolver autonomia pra mim aprender a
autonomia no sentido a gente poder
descobrir e poder inventar as próprias
regras
é porque é uma coisa que obedecer às
regras dos outros 11 a gente fazer
nossas próprias como eu quero viver
minha vida que é importante pra mim onde
eu quero chegar eu volto ao ponto
inicial
aprender a sobreviver no mundo que a
gente vive hoje com desafios complexos
desafios bem difícil disse 'olha aqui em
nossa cidade de mobilidade urbana até
violência à falta de segurança
até as perspectivas do futuro né nosso
crescimento
as nossas escolhas como pessoas e como
sociedade elas vão exigir de nós
eu acredito algumas dessas
idéias é desenvolver nosso auto controle
e na sua autonomia
a gente diz aprender muita coisa a
aprender coisas novas
desenvolver a curiosidade é por nós
mesmos pelo vizinho pelo próximo pela
cidade e assim talvez a gente consiga
sobreviver e sobreviveu digo passar
pelos nossos momentos difíceis evoluir e
por fim eu considero o porquê da resulta
da educação é chegar numa revolução que
a gente conseguir transformar de fato os
momento atual as dificuldades que a
gente tem é algo que a gente hoje não
consegue nem imagina mas que é
extremamente positivo e melhor pra todos
muito obrigado pessoal
muito obrigado